good morning Hank it's Tuesday wait what
is this background am I on a green
screen am I in Montana yes you are
it's Hank it's a reunion video it's
happening
Hank is making his triumphant but
temporary returned to vlogbrothers hello
hello I might make another video this
week about VidCon you're so bad at
paternity leave
okay Hank I got some question Tuesday
questions from nerdfighters for you
first how is Orrin doing Orion is your
son he's good he's good he's a good baby
so cute very cute
oh it's almost unbearable I think he may
have smiled at me this morning really
maybe he might have been pooping hey why
is there no sequel to The Fault in Our
Stars I would have been I think maybe
not the happiest book I also don't
really know how it could have happened
but believe me people in Hollywood did
make suggestions favorite Disney movie
go is it go a Disney movie I thought
that that was way too dark to be a
Disney movie I think it was rated R I
liked um the new one that lin-manuel
Miranda wrote the songs for the you know
lin-manuel Miranda wrote a song for the
new Star Wars movie Oh Bato do Munna
Munna
Obata do too bounnam unfortunately we
don't have the ability to clear the
rights to that song but on the upside
that was not a good enough version yeah
nobody knows what I was thinking for
copyright to come into play what is the
most surprising that wasn't the question
what is the most surprising thing about
having a baby the noise of the poops
yeah literally surprising sonic like
I'll be like poop within the first day
of ourn being home he he pooped with his
diaper Rafa was changing him oh hey
that's a rookie error I'm a rookie I
know Henry pooped on me so many times
Alice pooped on me never because I would
go in with like seven diapers I'd be
wearing like a diaper suit of armor I
went ahead and tried to catch it with my
hand oh I was like Oh switch glasses
every time we do this I'm like yours are
dirty now that's how I like to see the
world through smudged whens it's this is
pretty much exactly the same oh yeah Wow
the left eye is the exact it's almost
like we're brothers if you could take
one book to a desert island what book
would it be I've been thinking I was
like leave it there so no one could ever
read
none of brands the fountain here is my
idea it's a book where if you read it
forwards all that it's just the
collected works of Shakespeare so it's
rich it's complicated it's beautiful and
then if you read it backwards on like
the backsides of the pages are a
survival guide for how to live on a
desert island I was gonna go with the
king killer trilogy by Patrick Rothfuss
even though the last book isn't out yet
cuz I if I was gonna get stuck in a
desert island I'd better have that third
book I was gonna say how terrible would
it be you know what would happen though
because Pat Rothfuss is such a great guy
um you wouldn't get to leave the desert
island but an airplane would fly over
drop the third book when it comes out
and just wave goodbye to you yeah like a
bottle of water and you'd be like that's
all I needed thanks Hank you have any
self-care advice I I have lots but
self-care bunny has better self-care
advice yeah self-care bunny is just here
to remind you to be nice to yourself
yeah what did we learn from Nathan's
Ed's video you are a good burrito not
the best burrito you don't have to be
the best
okay stop putting so much pressure on
yourself you're a really good burrito
there's no best burrito that's right
there's only different kinds of good
burritos that's true actually
yeah that's true on many levels all
right Hank write an autobiography in
five words I guess mine would probably
be um is this mole a concern I wrote he
made stuff with John Oh
oh god that's so nice Hank thanks for
taking time away from your baby to make
a question Tuesday video thank Catherine
yeah I will see you right now I why are
we what when did this become a thing
what what do you know Alice does that
thumbs up yeah whatever you're like hey
Alice smile she doesn't smile but she's
like haha